in terms of what makes people a success
in Hollywood you've interviewed so many
heavy hitters do you see an it factor
with people or do you convenient it can
be manufactured there there are certain
people you interview who walk into a
room and gets everybody on their best
behavior in a good way and inspires the
lighting guy in the interview think the
the the producer the the PA who's there
is just ready to get more coffee
like everybody's just on and I've seen
it with people like I'm just working
with Seacrest you saw that when you were
where we were in London for the
bathrooms we have staff meeting of a
hundred people
pria like a pregame kind of going over
what we were doing there he was on it
and and everybody else was on it too and
it just rose everybody's worked ethic to
another place you see where Tom Cruise
walks in a room obviously and he
genuinely looks everyone in the eye
thanks them for coming asks them
questions and it makes everyone better
at what they do so I think that's what
the star power is is not so much how
necessarily they carry themselves but
more so how the way they carry
themselves affects other people and then
that lifts up their game so if you know
if you're an actor and you have that
quality and you guys are doing night
shoots in the rain and you know what the
crews going to go that extra mile for
you which is ultimately gonna make you
look better and make you a bigger star
so you see it I mean some people are
just there Will Smith Denzel Washington
and Tom Cruise Charlize Julia Roberts
there their enthusiasm is infectious and
they're there their charisma is
infectious drew Barrymore
Rivera is one of the sweetest people
I've ever met in my life I'm really
better like three times and I feel like
I've known her 20 years it's weird and
and a lot of people are like that and
and it's a testament to them being
genuine and presence and I don't know if
you see sometimes the lesser star who is
not paying attention to you when you
walk in the room
doesn't say eyes and looking at you when
you ask them a question they're looking
down here I think that ultimately
affects their their career because then
their star power this is where like the
rock by no means the most gifted actor
in the world and he'll be the first to
tell you that but has a great attitude
is professional is having fun and is
working for I don't know 15 years of
movies now or something like that ten
years of movies now I don't know like I
just think there is an it factor you do
see it with people there's a warmth to
certain stars Olivia Wilde is incredibly
genuine and intelligent sweet person and
she could be a diva and high maintenance
and have 50 handlers and it's not like
that at all you know and mostello this
is a normal 20-something girl you know
happens to be an it girl right now but
she's just somebody loves making movies
loves being on set loves telling stories
and and is having a good time with all
this other silly Fame stuff that comes
with it so oh no there's definitely
there's definitely a palpable in fact
there when you're around certain people
for sure but in the flip side of that
there's certain actors who are very
subdued and very quiet and soft-spoken
and you can tell they really come alive
when they're on set it really pisses me
off a lot of people hate on Kristen
Stewart for the way she does press
because that's a it's different skill
set than being an actress and Kristen's
definitely one of those people she
enjoys the process of making movies more
so than promoting movies while there are
other actors who love all the attention
of the fame and talking to journalists
and who can drive on that she very
candidly will say this isn't really for
me and I don't think someone should be I
don't know discredited for that she's a
terrific young actress and she doesn't
get a chance to always show it in some
of the Twilight films but you know in a
lot of the other movies she's made over
the years she really brings it and I
think she's one of those performers who
just loves being on set in the
collaboration with the crew and that
kind of summer camp feeling you have
when you're on an indie movie or a
smaller film and if you're around her I
don't know if you would say like boy
she's got that in fact her charisma but
she's got that it factor in terms of
being a hell of a talent and that will
supersede everything else I feel like
what would you say to indie filmmakers
who maybe follow more into that camp
maybe they're more introverts they're
more heady they're more sort of
analyzing themselves and they can't
really be social and it does get over
you get over yourself you can't be
social what does that mean I don't know
no I understand I got Joe but that's a
part of the business it's show business
you want people to feel compelled to
take hard earned money and spend it on
your movie or to take time out of their
day to watch your TV show so engage them
be personable you know what put on the
suit for two hours at your premiere from
your indie film press the flesh smile
take pictures and then when you get home
go back to your tortured tormented
artiste whatever it is you know whatever
Nine Inch Nails totally and scream in
the year I don't know I'm just saying
like you see with a lot of you look it's
really Johnny Depp Johnny Depp clearly
has figured it out and that he doesn't
want to be in round the Hollywood scene
anymore he lives in France he makes his
movies around the world and when it's go
time to sell a movie he puts on a happy
face for three weeks does the interviews
does whatever's asked of em and boom you
don't see him again for nine months or
whatever it is you know I don't know I
feel like there's nothing more
off-putting and more obnoxious to people
in my profession to movie goers then a
star who comes off as I'm grateful and I
don't want to be here and I hate this to
like suck it up your year you want
people to to see your films give a
reason why and it has to be it has to
come come from you on some level you
know so I don't know it's it's it's part
of the business and certain stars are
better at it than others and indie
filmmakers it's not coming out there
being a ham you don't have to come out
there and jazz hands it up and song and
dance like but just be a real person I
mean last night like what do young
doesn't need to do press to promote to
roll with lobbies in the 70s what do you
hasn't
you know but he came out there talk
to everybody last night give a nice
speech when he introduced the movie
introduced his cast took pictures with
the people from the festival and the
sponsors and then now we'll go off go
back to New York and walk make another
Ruby you know but that's part of the job
so so deal with it because it's not
going anywhere it's only gonna hurt you
if you don't figure it out
you